let me explain how if we go to the
political article please the problems
from for Joe Biden are serious here and
especially look at the Politico 2017 I
have the copy right here this is if you
look at it I got it right here somewhere
it is July
I'm sorry January 11th and it is in 2017
let me go back and read from this
particular article because this gets to
the heart of everything that the
Democrats are doing and what they've
done wrong and what they're going to
continue look at that Ukrainian
government officials try to help Hillary
Clinton undermine Trump and publicly
questioning his fitness for office they
also disseminated documents implicating
a top Trump aide in corruption and
suggested that they were investigating
the matter only to back away after the
election they helped Clinton's allies
research damaging information on Trump
and his advisers well and it continues
to mount for Sleepy creepy Uncle Joe
Rudy Giuliani is with us former New York
City Mayor I actually would like to see
you go and and tap out in Congress
because I believe Jay Sekulow your
partner all right I don't have any
experience in a courtroom no and I get
nervous public speaking and these people
are such intellectual heavyweights I
don't know if I can handle while he was
still a president-elect the Ukraine
admitted they were doing election and a
Fearon sin this country the president in
this call asked them to help get to the
bottom of what the media and the
Democrats said they wanted they're not
doing it Sean you just laid out the
reason why I was investigating and the
reason why the president United States
had an obligation to ask the president
of Ukraine to follow up on these
allegations because there is substantial
and I don't want to exaggerate it but
pretty close to overwhelming evidence
including a finding by a Ukrainian court
that Hillary Clinton and the Democrats
cooperated with Ukrainians with the
order coming directly from the White
House in January of
17 to dig up dirt on her political
opponent and they did the Vogel and
whoever that other person's story was in
Politico
I bet political regrets not printing
that actually because now they're doing
everything they can to cover up but in
fact they laid out the reasons why if I
didn't investigate it I'd be guilty of
malpractice you know they can they seem
to forget that I'm a lawyer
if I were defending a terrorist they'd
be going crazy that I was called before
a Senate committee all those civil
liberties groups would be saying right
to counsel how can they intimidate a
lawyer in his fearless pursuit of trying
to find justice I was not involved in
any election anything this started two
years before the election it started and
ended pretty much before the mullet
probe was over I was still gathering
evidence to prove his innocence and all
of a sudden I realized that there was a
frame-up a deliberate one at the highest
levels of our government and then a
colossal pay-for-play scheme at the
highest levels of the Obama
administration eerily similar to the
Clinton Foundation completely corrupt
behavior in which the Clintons sold her
office of Secretary of State for
millions in this case the Biden sold his
office for millions is there anybody
that believes that Ukraine or China
we're paying for hunter Biden's
expertise or do you have the common
sense to realize they were buying Joe
Biden's office and that is very damaging
to the United States Joe Biden was sent
to Ukraine to impart deal with
corruption and he helped to corrupt the
Ukraine he is a laughingstock we are
because we talk about corruption and
this guy puts his incompetence fun to
work for the most crooked oligarch in
Russia I mean it is outrageous the only
really sad part of this sean is how much
in the tank and how corrupt this
media has become they have corruption
staring them in the face and they close
their eyes to it and then they make up
charges against President Trump that
aren't true they don't look at this
whistleblower he is giving them hearsay
evidence the thing is filled with I
don't know I heard I overheard there's
not a single time he says I know
yesterday I produced a witness who is
under oath he is willing to give his
name he is willing to testify maybe one
of our Republicans in the Senate could
call him he's the guy that Biden fired
he's the guy that will testify under
oath he will face Biden and say you
corrupted my country you got me fired on
false pretext and then you had the case
against a corrupt company dismissed and
I'm going to tell you one other thing
Biden's corruption helped to cover up
all of the allegations of collusion
because there was a company involved run
by George Soros which was involved in
the investigation and that was closed
down to cut off all of the proof the
additional proof of just how far the
Democrats went in corrupting the 2016
election and in corrupting the Ukraine
mr. mayor the Vice President was put in
charge of Ukraine let's go to the
timeline at 2014 there's only months
after that put in charge to corrupt it
his son we can find no experience in
Ukraine none no experience in the energy
sector none or gas he had just been
thrown out of the Navy okay now tell you
millions of dollars to go on a company
that had it be reformed and the kid got
thrown out of the Navy after his father
put pull strings to get him in he got
thrown out tragically I guess failing a
drug test
but China doesn't pay a guy who fails
drug tests millions of dollars billions
in a private equity fund
sure as heck a crooked oligarch doesn't
hire a guy who's drug challenged to be
on his board
they bought Joe Biden's office wake up
Democrats you are covering up corruption
and by the time this is over you're
gonna be the party of corruption mr.
mayor they the guy's name is shokan he
has signed an affidavit he wants to test
drive he was nobody's hand Uncle John
here what he has he's we know talk to
John solid we talked DC I talked to the
washer both here's what we do know I'm
the first one to interview him Sean
well okay because the man is afraid and
if this guy is crooked he's not good at
it he's got a little cottage he doesn't
have a big Bentley like the phony
prosecutor they put on yesterday he's
got a little car and he's scared out of
his mind because these people there are
dangerous why would a vice president of
the United States of America use that
power he literally is shaking down
demanding in six hours the firing of a
Ukrainian prosecutor or he's going to
withhold taxpayer dollars so he's using
our money to shake this guy down in six
hours either fire him and it turns out
that this is the guy that is
investigating the company that is paying
his son seemingly has no experience
whatsoever all of these millions of
dollars and I guess the big the the
bigger question here is he got away with
it and it has to be that is not a paper
place heat from the moment you read the
New York Times article in 2015 and you
saw that Biden got away with having his
son pulling down millions from the
crookedest oligarch in Russia you knew
this was going to happen i prosecuted
corruption Democrats and Republicans I
can smell this Obama let this happen
when that article appeared in The Times
any honest president would have called
his vice president in and said Joe what
are you doing
you there to straighten out corruption
and you have your son who has no
capabilities getting millions from a
crook in the Ukraine or they may have
said because the Washington Post and all
of the swamp media allow us to commit
crimes and go after them for nonsense we
can get away with it and I believe
that's true
these people are enabled that's why
yesterday they actually put out a
document demanding that their
co-conspirators the press silenced me
right why do you think they're silencing
me because I'm not making any points
they're silencing me because I showed up
with an affidavit yesterday an accuser
who's willing to stand up and point the
finger at Joe Biden and say you're a
crook and I have the proof and I have
the documents and I've got the witness
we'll say the corroboration because
there are more witnesses where he came
from
and they're not going to escape this
Shawn the American people are fair
people and they don't like what they see
which is a family the Biden family that
has been using as an asset for
themselves
his public office going back to his
brother who was selling his Senate
office when he was a lobby in health
care yeah right scandal you travel by a
compliant crooked press we will get into
that issue of the health care then we're
going to also get into the billion five
in the China deal the double standard
you testify because I think Jay Sekulow
is absolutely right do you you don't
have to do anything oh I don't know I'm
weighing the alternatives I'm I'll kind
of like go through it I'll get all my
evidence together I'll get my charts
I don't know if they let me use
videotapes and tape recordings that I
have if they let me get some of the
evidence that I gathered and I have to
tell you Sean all this nonsense about I
was interfering the election I gathered
all this evidence before the Muller
probe ended so it was clearly under my
responsibility
as the lawyer for the President of the
United States listen I go final meeting
the final meeting that the Ukrainians
ask for a guide when the investigation
was over
look I go to polenta request a State
Department